he didn't get a burner phone what are
you a [ __ ] idiot dude did you call it
a murder phone or a bird or you call it
a murderer yeah you called that yeah you
got to get a murder thing
[Music]
we've got a tough one today oh no not
again Anthony this is just the news the
news isn't always happy go lucky guys
right sometimes you got to report the
real news so that people understand you
have a responsibility how dark this
world is sure no jokes this one no we
got to make some some jokes for sure
there's a little bit of poetic justice
that looks like I'm gonna ask you all to
deliver again though because no more
Poetic Justice dude hey please
let me do my job please hi okay just one
more give us a hint all right and then
we'll try to guess this has to do with
collecting a life insurance policy oh
someone killed someone's [ __ ] wife oh
no this one oh you saw this one Ryan
tell us what it is no it sucks yeah it
does sucks it sucks for a lot of reasons
a man named hakan isal aged 41 was
convicted of shoving his seven months
pregnant wife Samurai Sal 32 years old
off a cliff in the popular Beauty Spot
Butterfly Valley in mugula southern
turkey whoa in order to claim life
insurance that's not how that works
though this ain't even the one I'm
sticking dang what were you thinking of
just say it the one with the guy um so
there was like a murder of this dentist
woman she was like 60. she got killed by
this uh black dude and everybody was
like oh stop eating hey that's so [ __ ]
up turns out that that black dude was
hired by her Asian boyfriend
that one the Oakland one yeah oh that's
what we should have done
hey Anthony I think this is a great
article bro but he didn't he did it to
collect on the policy okay so are we
doing a twofer let's do it [ __ ] that one
it doesn't matter that one's wait wait
no no that was good no Joe doesn't like
the one though Joe doesn't like the
turkey story so let's do the [ __ ]
non-asian hate one I think it's on
Wednesday I think I think we actually
did this turkey one before there's a
couple ones in Turkey wait to push off a
cliff
I did one that was a push out the cliff
but it might be a different one I feel
like push off the cliff is very common
though okay the one where there's a
photo there's a photo we're going to the
no no
no Asian black I want to do the other
one too though
I feel like Anthony's at a piano recital
and the dad's like play the other song
I'm like I'm not doing this for me you
[ __ ] hard
the other way yeah this one's way better
I I think this is the one yeah
a boyfriend killed an Oakland dentist to
get her 12 million dollar estate that's
that's a whole different situation and
we're gonna show some photos
because we don't want to talk about
turkey
when Oakland's right there so let's talk
about these [ __ ] oh wow so what
happened is she a lawyer she's a dentist
oh yeah and then but she has her own
practice and she's a master pretty yeah
and then this this one guy he pulled up
and just executed her oh yeah and then
the whole like all the all the uh you
know like Asians never die Asians with
attitudes and like uh was it next shark
all the Instagram yeah they were just
like oh assassination more Asian hate
they all believe there's a hate crime
yeah did they post an update and then
and then yeah and then they realized
before we uh just jump to the end for
our viewers guys
um what do you think Dr Lily Shu age 60
was inside a parked Mercedes-Benz sedan
with her longtime boyfriend Nelson Chia
age 73 when a gunman now believed to be
33 year old Hashim Basin approached them
in a white Lexus and shot her dead at
the intersection of East 11th Street and
5th Avenue on August 21st
Shia who was arrested for his
involvement in the murder-for-hire plot
reportedly hung himself in his cell
hours after authorities announced his
arrest alongside basement no justice
what the [ __ ] was the point who get the
money no I know but like what was the
point is because they didn't want to
hear about the turkey life insurance
problem so we put up a pointless story
yeah but he created a scam to make money
we're talking the adults are talking
yeah that was the whole point of that
start with killing yourself instead dude
Jesus Christ you know do me the wrong
order all these people have cavities
they got nowhere to go yeah she
obviously was a great dentist yeah these
are up 30 percent technically it's still
Asian hate because he hates his wife
yeah it's Asian Navy it's Asian hate
yeah we gotta talk more about that so
according to police phone records
between Chia and Basin proved that the
two suspects had been plotting the
homicide he didn't get a burner phone
what are you a [ __ ] idiot do
it dude murder phone number
or you call her birth yeah you called
that yeah
uh but they were they were uh plotting
since early July prosecutors allege that
Chia and Shu killed by a Hitman for
financial gain that's clearly obvious
now uh what else is there up because
he's the main beneficiary because he's
they're not even married right you said
his boy yeah they're not married but she
named him a beneficiary for the for the
uh I think it's like he gets like a mill
like right away from Life Insurance what
does he do what's his [ __ ] job so
being a deadbeat the victim's boyfriend
Nelson gained control of many of her
financial accounts and set up trust so
that he would have income from her
estate for the rest of his life
oh damn but I mean this was old as [ __ ]
the rest of his life is like 30 you
gotta you gotta keep those things in the
secret man don't you don't you agree
that like when you do that you're kind
of like the people on my beneficiaries
don't all know that they're there yeah
but like
oh man I don't got assets to give I got
19 mil of this y'all man y'all are
getting a piece all you guys oh really
I'm a part of that that's tight I'm
gonna need that to come back because I
[ __ ] burnt all my money
it's so [ __ ] that he this guy did this
because he also threw a lot of like you
know the the Asian hate and the hate
crime [ __ ] through that dude under the
bus and caused all this infighting
really well yeah because now everyone
was like it sparked a lot of like oh
black people are just [ __ ] out to
kill us yeah you know like yeah people
don't read the follow-ups so yeah
exactly so at least it's good that all
these Outlets are trying really hard to
be like okay sorry about that whole
scare never mind so so Chia agreed to
provide Basin with a significant amount
of money for murdering shoot and just
like uh Ryan said uh as a trustee he
would have received one million dollars
immediately if she died so uh Chia and
Basin plan the day time and place of the
murder base in acquired vehicle
recruited a driver and waited to Ambush
you a block on from the location of the
appointment and she had drove you to the
agreed-upon location and it was recorded
don't do this over fun bro
allegedly paid Basin after gaining
control of shoes assets Basin is set to
be arraigned on Tuesday Morning did he
do it on venmo too did he [ __ ] send
him away from murder yeah like this
[ __ ] guy dude there's records of
everything it's a knife emojis
and then the knife and a gun and a tooth
no wonder he [ __ ] killed himself this
is also [ __ ] up because it says uh she
she and Shia that who lived together in
the Oakland Hills were romantically
involved for 10 years
already this is like a 10-year romantic
relationship they're already living
large in the Oakland Hills he's 73. what
more do you want dude you have it made
you haven't made 73 though you know what
I mean like what do you have total
[ __ ] garbage dude it's not like you
have your whole life if you have death
ahead of you already yeah okay right
what are you gonna do what is he gonna
do with the money because like
I mean he's not rich already like what
he's is he broke is he like yeah he
looks pretty rich he got glasses you
know or is it like or maybe he's like
the gigolo that he's like man she never
lets me use the money
I need more of it maybe it's just High
insecurity where he wants to die the
Richer person I don't [ __ ] know
because he literally has it all she's
younger than him she's more beautiful
than him bro he made it yes you know
obviously a good community of Samaritan
he won the game he wanted to get those
[ __ ] Chinese medicine balls
bro this guy probably walks around in
the morning
yeah bro you know and he's gonna kill
his [ __ ] girlfriend and then himself
after and at least stay alive right at
least free dental care too so I know
exactly that's the best because Dental
Care is not cheap it's just it yeah it
just makes it even more like stupid when
you see like a sloppy murder plot for I
mean it's already [ __ ] up that you
decided to kill her but like especially
if it's for insurance right like you got
to make sure everything is [ __ ]
buttoned away if you want to kill
somebody
and you're a beneficiary of them dying
yeah they'll look at you you idiot yeah
dude already so you have to make sure
everything's buttoned away so like yeah
the craziest thing is he planned this
with him in the car to watch her get
blasted right in front of her that's
some cold [ __ ] dude yeah they've been
fighting for the last 10 years that's
what I think been happening 10-year
relationships it's probably mean huh
yeah
it's all her fault we're all thinking it
we're all thinking it if she's Rich
she's mean okay and I would be pissed if
I was the guy that got paid to shoot her
and then this guy just goes and kills
himself in his jail cell then that other
guy's in jail did you get paid though
you know what I'm saying
oh yeah they got caught it don't matter
if you get paid if you get caught if
you're sloppy with your [ __ ] that's
right they did get paid though it is
just dumb when like when it's when it's
[ __ ] uh murder For Hire like in the
situation where any woman dies they
always look at the relationship first so
you're already [ __ ] there but on top
of that you did it by her getting shot
which is like push her down some [ __ ]
stairs
assassination yeah like that's so like
really bring that story back so what's
the turkey one was it was the turkey one
any more interesting than this one well
other than the fact that she was seven
months pregnant defined interesting
that's sad yeah there's more victims
what happened he always has the sad
articles
Ryan that was a great article thanks for
bringing it up says Joe
I hate this job it's so sad you brought
up the the pregnant one I was like I
mean this is a great article you guys
mind turning off the cameras where would
you go preggers I'm in well I mean like
[ __ ] you're right he did the guy in
Turkey did plea insanity and then they
denied it what happened yeah I misread
that one wow you're now you're telling
us the interesting videos over Dude
foreign
[Music]